s'appelle sofiane camille ch ou encore
jean-paul salarié chez depuis des
décennies sur ce site renault de choisy
le roi ils vont devoir plier bagages sur
les 14 sites de france c'est en effet le
seul qui doit fermer à l'horizon 2022 un
choix leur reste partir exercer à 60
kilomètres de là dans l' usine de flins
dans les yvelines ou quitter
l'entreprise
une situation intenable pour de nombreux
salariés
mon sentiment c'est déjà vous voyez on
sort de deux mois de confinement
donc on a des jeunes crise sanitaire et
vous revenez au travail et puis vous
apprenez ce genre de choses donc c'est
pas facile
encaisser du jour au lendemain on
apprend par la presse que vous servez à
rien on va fermer votre site
par contre on va vous le délocaliser sur
flins mais il ya 2600 personnes nous on
est on est à peu près 300 donc on
s'interroge il y aura pas assez de
boulot pour tout le monde
où cette décision on la comprend pas ou
la refuse parce que vous nous expliquer
rien n'y a pas de raison qu'on parte vu
nos résultats nos derniers résultats du
site on a eu un bilan social et le
dernière qui a montré que le niveau des
indicateurs qu'ils soient économiques
environnementales
enfin voilà on a super performer quoi
donc les gens comprennent pas
aujourd'hui c'est pour ça qu'ils sont là
d'ailleurs pour ça qu'ils sont révoltés
parce que on nous explique que rien ce
projet de restructuration renault
s'appuierait sur des mesures de
reconversion de mobilité interne et de
départs volontaires premier actionnaire
du constructeur automobile
l état qui détient 15% du capital a
proposé un prêt de 5 milliards d'euros
sans que cela ait suffi à sauver tous
les emplois pour de nombreux élus
politiques dont certains issus de la
majorité présidentielle le gouvernement
a sa part de responsabilité dans la
gestion de cette crise sociale pour ce
dossier je suis extrêmement désaccord
avec le ministre de l'économie
effectivement sur ce qui a pu être fait
parce que je considère que une usine qui
chaque année sort entre 40000 boîte
moteur entre 39 mille boîtes de vitesses
qui sont reconditionnés qui sont
réemployés
il est aberrant aujourd'hui de procéder
à une fermeture de cette usine de mettre
si je fumais qui seront ainsi sur l'eau
sur le carreau 265 salariés
ce site de renault est exemplaire parce
que il rentre dans une démarche
d'économie vertueuse puisque le travail
qui est fait ici s'inscrit dans la
démarche de recyclage économiser
milliards d'euros sur trois ans c'est
l'objectif affiché par la direction du
groupe
conséquence 15000 postes doivent être
supprimés dans le monde dont 4600 en
france pour ma part je pense que ces
concertations se dérouleront très bien
elles se font sur la base évidemment
d'une absence de licenciements secs
lorsqu'il s'agira des mesures concernant
les personnes je lui ai indiqué très
clairement et pour résumer la situation
j'ai dit que ne n'y aura pas de
souffrance sociale dans le développement
de ce plan nous y tenons tous et je m'en
serais pour ma part le garant et donc
nous trouverons des solutions pour tout
le monde
nous n'avons pas chez renault l'habitude
de laisser les gens au bord de la route
et par conséquent c'est pas maintenant
nous allons changer agir plus
efficacement
c'est justement ce qu'envisage de faire
de nombreuses organisations syndicales
du site de choisy-le-roi pour qui la
pilule a encore beaucoup de mal à passer